Good afternoon, everyone.
Welcome to our mini symposium,
"Population Sciences at the Forefront: Risk Factors Influencing
Cancer Incidence and Survival."
It's my pleasure to co-chair this session with
Dr. Melissa Troster.
Population sciences, as you know, are very essential
to advancing cancer research,
not only on identifying who is at risk, but in
understanding the complex interplay of lifestyle,
clinical, environmental, genetic, structural factors that shape
cancer incidence and survival.
So today's session
will bring together an outstanding set of studies spanning the
continuum from early life exposures to
survivorship, and from population-level risk factors to
genomic discovery.
We will begin with Phuong Anh Le, who examines
adherence to planetary health diet during
adolescence and its association with
breast cancer risks, highlighting the importance of early life
exposures.
And then next, Kevin Chen will present on
cardiorespiratory multimorbidity and lung cancer risks,
offering insights into how coexisting
chronic conditions may influence cancer development.
Catherine De La Torre Cineiros will then examine
generation immigration status and
gastric cancer incidence among Japanese
descendants in the multiethnic cohort, which underscore the
importance of population heterogeneity.
We then move into translational research with Loukas
Mavromatis, who will discuss an EHR-based model for
pancreatic cancer risk stratification.
Following this, Shital Hardikar will explore metabolic
factors and survival outcomes after colorectal cancer.
We will then hear from Sakshat Chintala, who examines
disparities in telehealth utilization in cancer
care, highlighting important issues in health equity.
And finally, we will conclude with a presentation from the
NCI Confluence Project, the largest
multi-ancestry GWAS study of breast cancer to date.
So across these talks, key themes include
life course exposures, multimorbidity,
population diversity,
and the integration of epidemiology with clinical data and genomics.
So with that, I'm delighted to introduce our first speaker,
Phuong Anh Le.
I
think
you
have
to hit the
computer.
Sorry.
Try just hitting it. Just check.
Okay.
Hello, everyone. My name is Phuong Anh.
I'm a PhD student at the Harvard Chan School of Public Health,
and I'm honored to be here today to share with you
our current research looking at the adherence to the EAT-Lancet reference
diet in adolescence and the risk of invasive breast cancer
in adulthood among US women.
And so why are we interested in adolescent diet?
Adolescence is a special period that is marked by significant
hormone changes and rapid proliferation of the breast tissues,
making it a susceptible window for breast carcinogenesis.
However, despite the importance of this period, most current
studies focus on the adult diet and breast cancer, and mainly it's
because there aren't a lot of studies that have data on
adolescent diet.
According to a recent systematic review and meta-analysis,
several adolescent dietary factors were found to
significantly reduce the risk of adult breast cancer,
including fruit and vegetables, soy, dietary
fiber, and vegetable fat.
Just a little background on the dietary pattern that we are looking at today,
which is called the Planetary Health Dietary Index.
So in 2019, the EAT-Lancet Commission proposed
a dietary pattern that is simultaneously beneficial for human
health as well as for the sustainability of the planet.
And then subsequently, this dietary pattern, called the
Planetary Health Dietary Index, was developed to quantify adherence
to this EAT-Lancet reference diet.
And from previous research, we know that adherence to this diet
was linked to a lower risk of cardiovascular disease, type 2 diabetes,
as well as all-cause mortality.
And in our group, we found that a higher adult
adherence to this Planetary Health Dietary Index was
associated with a lower breast cancer risk, and we saw a
stronger association for ER-negative tumors.
And with all of this, that's why we are interested in looking at adolescent
Planetary Health Dietary Index. So this is a score that
contains a sum of 14 food groups characterized by high
intake of whole grain, vegetables, fruits-
nuts, legumes, unsaturated oils, with low to
moderate intake of dairy, poultry, egg, and fish, and
low to limited intake of starchy vegetables, red processed meat,
added saturated fat, and added sugar and sugar from juice.
And so to just reiterate our study objectives, we
wanted to assess the association between adolescent Planetary
Health Dietary Index and subsequent risk of breast cancer.
And we will also examine if the association differ by estrogen
status,
receptor status of the tumors,
by menopausal status at diagnosis, as well as by body mass
index at age 18.
So we used the Nurses' Health Study Too, which is a well-known cohort
of more than 100,000 nurses. And these
participants filled out questionnaires every two years to report their
outcome, including breast cancer, as well as other
covariates like lifestyle factors and reproductive factors.
And within this cohort, there were more than
47,000 women,
age 33 and 52 years old at baseline, filled out
a validated 124-item food frequency questionnaire in
1998 to recall their adolescent diet.
And then we followed them prospectively from 1998 until
2019, which is about 20 years of follow-up.
And as you can see in this diagram, the key point is that in
1998, these participants recalled their adolescent diet years
ago, so 15 to 35 years ago. But the study design is
prospective, because we followed them prospectively from
for incident breast cancer.
And our exposure is the quartiles of the adolescent PHDI, and we
used cause proportional hazard models to look at these associations.
And in our models, we adjusted for potential
confounders of this association, as well as
well-known risk factors for breast cancer, including adolescent
characteristics as well as adult reproductive and lifestyle factors.
And in a separate model, we also adjusted for weight change to
see if the association was attenuated after we account for weight
change.
So just briefly to look at the baseline characteristics of the participants.
So across quartiles of the PHDI, those who were
at higher quartiles had lower adolescent total energy
intake,
as well as less likely to have ever drunk alcohol
and as well as less likely to have ever
used oral contraceptive. But interestingly, those who were at higher
quartiles were more likely to have early age at
menarche.
Looking at the adult factors, we also saw that those who were
at the higher quartiles has less weight change
since age 18, more adult physical activity,
and
less likely to have ever had children.
They were also
more likely to have ever breastfed.
And among post-menopausal women, those with higher
quartiles were also less likely to have ever used
post-menopausal hormone.
And this is the main results of our study.
So looking at adolescent PHDI and breast cancer,
we did not see an association for overall invasive breast
cancer as well as for ER-positive breast cancer.
However, we did see that adhering to this EAT-Lancet reference
diet during adolescence significantly reduced future risks of
breast cancer by more than 30%.
And what is noteworthy is that after we adjust for potential
confounders, the associations did not change a lot
throughout our models.
And the association remained significant even after adjusting for weight change
since age 18.
And then we looked further to see if this association differs by menopausal
status as well as by subgroups of BMI at age 18.
And for overall invasive breast cancer, we did not see any
effect modification by menopausal status as well as by
BMI at age 18. And similarly, for ER-positive breast
cancer, we did not see any differences in the association
across subgroups of menopausal status as well as subgroups of BMI at
age 18.
But for ER-negative breast cancer, we saw something different.
So we saw that among premenopausal ER-negative breast
cancer, there was a significant reductions in breast cancer risk.
However, it was not significant among post-menopausal
ER-negative breast cancer.
And when looking at BMI at age 18 subgroups, we also saw a
significant association among those who were below 21
kilogram per meter square
at age 18, but did not see a significant association for the other
group.
However, looking at these results, it's important to keep in mind
that our sample size was somewhat limited when looking at
these subgroups. For instance, we only had 83 cases
of premenopausal ER-negative breast cancer.
And then we just go a little bit further and try to see
which food groups have driven the
association we have seen in ER-negative breast cancer.
So we saw that whole fruits was protective for breast cancer.
However, saturated fat and added saturated fat and trans fat
increased the risk of future breast
cancer.And for premenopausal
ER-negative breast cancer, we also see that whole fruits were protective,
and added saturated fat and trans fat increased the risk.
And we additionally saw that starchy vegetables
slightly increased the risk for premenopausal
ER-negative breast cancer. But again, we only had 83 cases for
this subgroup.
So what do we interpret and kind of key message
out of all of this?
So we found that greater adherence to the EAT-Lancet diet in
adolescent was associated with a lower risk of ER-negative
breast cancer, particularly among premenopausal women,
and among those with BMI less than 21 kilogram per meter square
at age 18. And this EAT-Lancet
diet again was developed so that it was beneficial for both
humans and sustainable for the planet.
And the apparent specificity that we saw for ER-negative tumors is
notable because we do not know a lot of modifiable risk
factors for this subtype, although this is the more aggressive subtype
of breast cancer.
And given the fact that there are limitations to our studies, especially the
recalled aspect of the diet, additional prospective
cohort studies are needed, especially to look at more
intermediate outcomes like mammographic density or benign breast
disease,
would be needed to confirm this hypothesis.
And if confirmed, a plant-forward adolescent diet may have dual
benefits for breast cancer prevention as well as for planetary health.
And lastly, I would like to thank my co-authors,
funders, as well as special thanks to the Nurses' Health Study 2 participants
for their longstanding dedication and invaluable contribution to this
research.
Thank you for listening.
Thank you for the great talk. I was wondering if you have any further
plan to look for most susceptible window period
for exposure to this diet by
comparing, I mean, applying the same method to the different
age groups, including adolescents and different age groups into adults,
so that we can find if the adolescent period is more
susceptible than other age group in terms of
exposure period.
Yeah. So,
a previous study in our group looked at this pattern in the
adult diet and saw similar
results with this study. So we also found that
adherence to this diet during adult reduced the risk of overall breast cancer as
well as in stronger associations for ER-negative breast cancer.
And so one of the next step that we are thinking about is to look
at whether people who are consistently adhering to
this diet, both in adolescent and adult, would reduce
the risk of cancer. Yeah.
Have you looked into the effect size?
I'm sorry?
Have you compared the effect size in adolescents and
adulthood?
I don't have the number for the adults on top of my mind,
but what was similar was
that both of the studies found stronger
association for ER-negative breast cancer.
Okay. Thank you.
Thank you.
Hi. I just have a quick question.
I was wondering if you can explain the rationale for the BMI to be
21.1?
Yeah. So,
this is just something particular to this particular study because,
in adolescent period, we did not have a lot of women that were
above the usual 25 BMI cutoff. So that's
why we just wanted to use a cutoff that
help us separate two groups of women, kind of
leaner and less lean women for it to look at.
Yeah.
Thank you.
I'm just curious, how did race play into this, given the increased
prevalence in Black women and relationship with
BMI, et cetera?
Yeah. Thank you for your question.
So actually, the reason why I did not mention
race is because the Nurses' Health Study was
predominantly white. So that's why. Yeah.
Sorry. I make
a mess.
Okay.
Slide. Just have to click.
Push that.
This one?
Here.
Okay.
Push this point.
Yes. Okay.
Good afternoon, everyone. My name is Wang Peng from Tianjin Medical University
Cancer Institute and Hospital.
It's my great honor to be here to present our study
titled, "Cardiorespiratory Multimorbidity and Lung Cancer
Risk: A Population-Based Cohort
Study."According to
the Global CAN 2022, lung cancer remains the most
commonly diagnosed cancer and the leading cause
of cancer mortality worldwide. Beyond the
established risk factors such as smoking, air
pollution or household air pollution,
occupational exposure,
multiple chronic diseases have been reported to be related to
higher lung cancer risk.
Among which,
chronic respiratory disease and cardiovascular disease
represent the two major disease
categories with significant
epidemiological links to lung cancer, even after
adjusting the shared risk factors such as
smoking. However, most existing
studies have primarily focused on the individual
disease rather than multimorbidity.
In reality, in clinical practice, the CRD and
the CVD frequently coexist
as cardiorespiratory multimorbidity.
It is reported that in CRD patients, the
prevalence of CVD ranges from 30% to
70%,
or in CVD patients, the progression ranges
from 10% to 40%.
Individuals with CRM tend to have
worse outcome, such as higher mortality,
increased hospitalizations, impaired quality of life, and
severe respiratory impairment.
However, whether CRM is associated with higher lung
cancer risk remain unclear. Also, it is
unclear that
whether CRM may serve as a high-risk
intermediate state in the progression from single
CRD or CVD to CRM, and what
modifiable factors may affecting this
disease progression.
So this study aimed to evaluate the
association between cardiorespiratory multimorbidity and lung
cancer risk.
Next, we aim to characterize
disease progression trajectories from health through single
CRD or CVD to CRM, and then to
lung cancer. Finally, we aim to explore
the role of healthy lifestyle in the occurrence
of CRM and its progression to lung cancer.
This study was based on the UK Biobank.
We exclude
participants from the UK Biobank who are free of
cancer, CRD, or CVD at baseline and had
a
middle follow-up time of more than one year.
The middle follow-up duration was 13.7 years.
The cardiorespiratory multimorbidity was defined as the
co-occurrence of at least one CRD or
one CVD. The CRD included
COPD and asthma, and the CVD included six
major cardiovascular conditions such as
angina,
myocardial infarction, atrial fibrillation, heart failure,
peripheral vascular disease, and stroke.
And the study outcome was incident lung cancer.
Then
we calculated the healthy lifestyle score.
It include the diet, healthy activity, smoking,
and BMI, which is related to
health.
We first used time-varying Cox regression model to
explore the association between CRM and lung cancer
incidence. Then we further use a
multi-state model to construct disease
trajectories from health to single CRD or
CVD to CRM, and finally to lung cancer.
And we estimate
transition intensity probability and the progression time,
and assess the role of lifestyle in the disease
progression.
Then let me move on to the result. First,
the Cox models shows, compared with the
healthy participants,
individuals with CRM had the highest
lung cancer incidence and the highest lung cancer risk,
with a hazard ratio of 4.11, followed
by single CRD and single CVD.
Then we found among CRD,
CRM combinations, the combination of COPD
and peripheral vascular disease, heart
failure, and myocardial infarction saw
the highest lung cancer risk.
Then we further constructed the disease trajectory
progression
from health state through CRD, CVD, or CRM to lung cancer.
Look at the figure in the left.
We found during follow-up, 22% of
CRD participants
progressed to CRM, compared with
4.9% of CVD patients.
Importantly,
the CRM showed the highest transition progression to
lung cancer with a progression of 2.8.
Then we divided the CRM into specific
CRM combinations, and we also findThe
COPD combined with heart failure, peripheral vascular disease,
and myocardial showed the highest transition
progression to lung cancer.
Then we calculated the transition
intensity, probability, and the progression time
to lung cancer across different disease
status. We found during follow-up,
CRM showed the highest transition intensity and
transition probability to lung cancer.
As for transition time, we also found CRM was
associated with shorter progression time to lung cancer,
although the differences were modest.
Then we explored the role of healthy lifestyle in the
disease progression. We found a healthy
lifestyle was associated with lower transition risk
of all transition stages.
Specifically, healthy lifestyle was associated with
34% lower and
54% lower
risk of progression from single CRD or
CVD to CRM. For the transition from CRM to
lung cancer, we found healthy lifestyle was associated with
57% lower risk.
Then we explored the four healthy lifestyle
components
in the disease progression. We found all four
healthy lifestyle components was associated with
reduced risk
in the progression from single CRD or CVD to CRM.
For the transition from CRM to lung cancer, we found only
no smoking and healthy diet was associated
lower risk of the transition from CRM to lung
cancer.
In conclusion, we found CRM was linked to higher
lung cancer risk and shorter progression time than
single disease. And it may represent a
critical high-risk intermediate state from a single
disease to lung cancer.
From a public health perspective,
prevention and management targeting
CRM may enhance lung cancer prevention,
and healthy lifestyle may serve as a potential
modifiable target for preventing CRM and lung cancer.
Finally, I would like to thank all members of our research team,
especially my supervisor, Professor Kexin Chen,
and all participants and staff of the UK Biobank.
That's all. Thank you.
I'm happy to take any questions. Please.
Hi. Damon Jia from Vanderbilt. I have a question.
So from a
patient with a single disease-
Mm.
... he or she can progress to lung cancer directly or instead
of progress to CRM.
Yes.
So for this patient,
how did you consider the competing risk?
Because these two outcome are competing each other-
Okay
... this single disease patient.
Okay.
I use a multi-state model to according
for the competing risk because this model is
developed to according this
problem.
Competing risk.
Yes.
Any questions?
Hi. Great talk. I wanted to ask, you found an
association between healthy lifestyle and
decreased-
Yes
... lung cancer risk in people with
CRM.
Was there a way you could adjust to check for reverse causality there?
Because my instinct would be that people with CRM who
are able to lead healthier lifestyles, chiefly to do with physical
activity-
Mm
... might be because they're healthier to begin with, and therefore, at lower risk
of lung cancer.
Sorry. Could you please slow-
Yeah
... little slower?
Absolutely.
Okay.
So my instinct would be, and I'm not an
expert in this area-
Mm
... that if you take two people with CRM-
... and one of them is leading a healthier lifestyle-
Mm
... and the other one isn't-
... then the reason that the person who is leading a healthier lifestyle
might be doing that is because they are healthier to
start with. They're more capable of taking on the physical activity-
Mm
... that comes with a healthier lifestyle.
Mm.
So by virtue of being healthier, that could be the reason
for the decreased lung cancer risk rather than the effect of the physical
activity. I suspect it's working in both directions.
I just wonder if you can be corrected at all for reverse causality.
Sir,
I want to make sure. Your question is if a
patients with CRM will take a healthy
lifestyle?
Uh-
Among people who... If you have CRM and
you
are leading a healthy lifestyle-
Mm
... yeah, then it might be because you are more capable of
exercising.
Mm.
Which would probably decrease your lung cancer risk.
Sorry, maybe need to talk a little after this lecture. Okay.
Okay. Thank you very much.
Sorry.
Wonderful talk. It was very interesting.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Oh, yeah
Good afternoon. My name is Catherine De La Torre.
I am a postdoc fellow at Rogers Cancer Institute,
and today I will present our work on how generational
immigration status influence gastric cancer incidence among
Japanese descendants in the United States using data from the
Multi-Ethnic Cohort Study.
I have no financial relationship to disclose.
And so
gastric cancer is a lethal disease in the United States.
Last year, there were more than 3,000 new
cases diagnosed, with nearly one-third of
patients dying from this disease.
However, this burden is not even proportionally,
so there are certain populations within the United
States that face higher incidence and mortality of gastric cancer.
These high-risk groups includes racial and ethnic minorities
such as Asian Americans and Pacific Islanders, Hispanics or
Latinos, and Black and African Americans, as well as immigrants
from high incidence regions such as Korea, Japan,
Russia, China, and Central and South America's countries.
Other high-risk group also includes
patients or individuals with first degree of family history of gastric
cancer. As you can see here in this figure,
all racial and ethnic minorities have a higher incidence
when we compare
to non-Hispanic whites. And particularly, the first
generation of Japanese and Korean have the
highest incidence when we compare with
non-Hispanic whites.
So we can clearly define
the high-risk groups, but there is still one question that is
unanswered, and that question is: What happens to gastric cancer risk after
immigration to the United States in later generations?
So we know that gastric cancer remains highly prevalent in regions such as East
Asia, Central America, and South America, as we can see here in this
map in the darker areas. And many
immigrants in the United States originate from these high
incidence areas.
Previous studies have already shown that first
generational immigrants in the United States have
gastric cancer rates similar to those in their countries of origin.
The traditional assumption is that the risk decline
across generations as the individuals adapt
to new environments,
new lifestyles, diet, and different healthcare
systems.
So based on that, our hypothesis was that gastric cancer risk decreases
in later immigrant generations but remains higher than in
non-Hispanic whites. This led to our research question on how
does gastric cancer risk change across first, second, and
third-generation immigrants compared with non-Hispanic whites.
So our specific aim was to evaluate the association of generational
immigration status on the risk of gastric cancer among
individuals with Japanese ancestry.
For doing that, we used the Multi-Ethnic Cohort Study, which is a
prospective cohort that recruit individuals
age from 45 to 75 that was residents in
Hawaii and California between 1993 and
1996.
The cancer
cases were identified
through state cancer registries.
For our analytical cohort,
we limited to those who self-report Japanese ancestry
and being non-Hispanic whites. Also, we limited to those
participants and their parents who were born only in US and Japan,
and we excluded missing information on covariates.
So we ended up with a final data set of
more than 94,000 participants.
For the statistical analysis, we use
multivariate Cox hazard regression models
adjusted for demographics, lifestyle factors,
and clinical factors
such as a family history, sodium fruit consumption, alcohol
intake, smoking, education, BMI, and
history of diabetes, ulcers, and polyps.
We also test linear trend across
generation categories.
So these are the characteristics of our population.
So
we have a median follow-up around 20 years with
almost 17 point a million person years,
where we identify 716 gastric cancer cases,
and our population had a median age of 61 years
and a proportion of 47 males.
As we can see here in table one, when we compared
the participants who didn't have or didn't develop gastric cancer,
those who did develop gastric cancer were older,
male,
have a first-degree gastric family history,
have a lower education attainment, lower BMI, and have
report higher fruit consumption, soda consumption,
and
smoking exposure, as well as history of diabetes, ulcers,
and polyps.
For the-Independent
variable.
We define Japanese generational immigration status
based on the participants' and their parents'
birthplace. So we have the first generation that includes
individuals that were born in Japan with both parents born in Japan,
and that accounts to 4%.
Second generation includes two categories, those who were born
in the U.S. with both parents born in Japan,
which accounts to 25%,
and also those who were born in the U.S.
with at least one parent born in Japan,
which represents 9% of our cohort.
For the third generation, that includes
participants born in the U.S. with both parents born in the U.S., and
we use non-Hispanic whites as our reference,
representing 44% in our
cohort study.
So when we
evaluate the characteristics of our population, the generational immigration
status, we observed that the first-generation immigrants
have a higher sodium intake and were more likely to be
never smokers compared to later generations and
non-Hispanic whites.
In contrast, we also observed that first-generation
immigrants have a lower BMI and a lower prevalence of
diabetes and intestinal polyps
compared to later generations and non-Hispanic whites as well.
This figure shows our primary findings,
and you can see here that the risk of gastric
cancer declines progressively across all three
generations.
The first generation has nearly
five times higher risk when we compare to non-Hispanic
whites. And although the risk declines over
generations, it never fully converges.
So even for the third generation, the risk is
2.5 times higher when we compare to non-Hispanic whites.
And this pattern was similar for men and for women.
This figure shows that the cumulative
risk of the first, second, and third generations of
Japanese descendants
is higher compared to non-Hispanic whites.
And also,
the
gastric cancer developed in these Japanese
descendants starts earlier
when we compare to non-Hispanic whites.
So for non-Hispanic whites, the slope
starts up around 65
years old, and for the Japanese descendants,
we can see here that the angle up is around
55.
So because the risk factors for
gastric cancer are
different based on the location, we
analyzed cardia and non-cardia separately.
So for cardia, the number of cases were relatively
small,
so it was hard to get some final conclusions.
But for non-cardia, as you can see here, the risk
was more pronounced
and consistent among all these three generations.
And this figure also shows
that we try to
see if there's these
factors as family history, education, BMI, smoking status, and
sodium consumption influence or modify the
relationship between generational status and
gastric cancer risk.
As you can notice here, there was no
effect modification.
These
five
factors did not modify the association between
generational status of Japanese
descendants and gastric cancer risk.
This is a separate analysis that we
did. So
we asked whether
this pattern that we observed for Japanese descendants,
we can
generalize for other high-risk groups.
So using the same multi-ethnic cohort study,
with the similar analytic approach,
we
tried to see if there's some difference.
So in contrast of Japanese descendants, where the risk
declines over generations,
we saw that for Latinos, the risk
remains
uniform and did not
differ by generation.
So
this means that the history of immigration and
the generation
affect the risk of gastric cancer
differently for different populations.
So
if you're interested to know more about
our findings in the Latino descendants, we invite you to
stop by our poster tomorrow afternoon in the
poster session for cancer surveillance.So
in summary, all generations of Japanese descendants have
a higher risk of gastric cancer compared with non-Hispanic whites.
The first generation had the highest risk and decrease in subsequent
generations. And this pattern was more pronounced for
non-cardiac gastric cancer. So the takeaway message
from our study is that even after multiple generations in the
United States, the Japanese ancestry individuals remain at
substantially higher risk of gastric cancer.
So these findings underscore the importance of incorporating
immigration history and generational status into gastric cancer
risk assessment, prediction,
risk informed target prevention, and screening strategies.
Thank you for listening, and I'm happy to take any questions.
You mentioned you checked the risk factor and found
many risk factor not
interact with the trend you observe for the immigration.
Was HP infection included? Because it is a
strong risk factor for gastric cancer and, given the
East Asian
eating style, they usually having a meal together and
HP infection remain across the generations.
So that's a great question, and unfortunately,
MEC doesn't have information regarding H. pylori.
So
we include
information about ulcer that can be related with H.
pylori,
and we try to perform a sensitivity analysis,
like a qualitative
bias analysis when we don't have these type of confounders.
But the issue of doing that was that there is not
information regarding H. pylori by
descendants. What we know right now is that H.
pylori decreases over time when we spend time in the
US, and there's already published studies about that.
So even for the third generation in our
study, the risk is increased compared to
non-Hispanic whites. So that's mean that it should be something else,
like biologically,
more than just H. pylori, because for first generation,
H. pylori makes sense because you probably get the infection from
your country of origin. But what happened with second and especially in
third generation, that H. pylori shouldn't be one of the
highest risk factors. But yeah, we don't have that data in our
cohort to just confirm that.
Another question?
Okay. Thank you.
Hello, everyone.
My name is Lucas Mavromatis. I'm a medical student and master's student
in the Division of Precision Medicine at NYU Grossman School of Medicine.
And today, I'll be talking to you about PRIME, a parsimonious risk stratification
model for pancreatic cancer.
I have no disclosures.
So as many of you know, early detection is a key challenge in
pancreatic cancer. While pancreatic cancer is a relatively uncommon cancer in
the United States, the 10th most incident cancer, it is the third leading
cause of cancer death and is projected to soon overtake
colorectal cancer and become the second leading cause of cancer death.
Moreover, it's the deadliest cancer type without population level guideline
recommended screening.
And while we have made incremental gains in the five-year survival for pancreatic
cancer over the last couple of decades,
five-year survival remains notably low at 13%.
And most of our gains, as you can see in the figure on the right, are in the
context of early stage, Stage 1A and 1B disease,
through advancements in adjuvant neoadjuvant therapy.
Really late stage disease has not budged over the last few
decades, and hopefully that will change with some of the targeted therapies that
are coming out now.
So current screening guidelines recommend pancreatic
cancer surveillance for certain individuals with high effect size
risk factors for pancreatic cancer.
Various guideline organizations recommend screening for patients
with PGVs, pathogenic germline variants in genes like BRCA,
as well as patients with a very strong family history of pancreatic cancer and no
pathogenic germline variants.
Gastroenterological associations also recommend surveillance for patients with
certain mucinous cysts that have
characteristics that indicate a high malignant potential.
But that leaves 80% of cases of PDAC without any sort of
early detection pathway or guideline recommended screening.
So recently, this Define Enrich Find paradigm has
been proposed to allow for the earlier detection of this
"sporadic PDAC."
So the first step in this paradigm involves defining a higher risk population
with higher incidence of PDAC using an EHR-based risk model.
After that, these higher risk individuals would be screened with a blood-based
biomarker test that would have appropriate and sufficient performance
characteristics in a higher risk population to be clinically useful.
And then finally, individuals who are positive for both the first steps of this
sequence would
undergo diagnostic imaging, such as MRI.
This effectively reserves the most costly and
effective screening method, which is imaging, for the highest risk
patients.So in this study, we try to address this first
step of this paradigm, this define step, by attempting to
develop a validated and interpretable EHR model to define a high-risk
population for PDAC.
So other models have been developed to identify high-risk PDAC
populations. Here are some of the notable ones.
So NPAC is a well-validated, the only prospectively
validated, and it's a deployable model
that basically risk stratifies individuals ages 50 plus who have
new onset diabetes. It includes variables including
glucose trajectory, weight trajectory, age of diagnosis of
T2D. But of course, it's only applicable to individuals
who have new onset diabetes, and this is a minority of PDAC cases.
Cancer RiskNet is another notable example of one of these EHR models.
This is a transformer-based model that uses ICD codes
as inputs and was developed in a large Danish registry.
It performed very well there. It was attempted to validate in
the US, in the VA population,
and discrimination dropped from 0.88 to 0.71.
This kind of underscores the challenge and the importance of
developing these models in diverse clinical populations that
sort of reflect the heterogeneity of the US clinical population.
Additionally, this model included some non-specific codes like observation for
suspected disease and uncertain neoplasm that were potentially suggestive of
PDAC workup that was already ongoing.
So our goal was to build on these models and use variables that precede clinical
suspicion rather than markers of ongoing workup to develop, again, an
interpretable and deployable risk stratification model for PDAC that
would generalize across US health systems.
To do this, we used the OptumLabs Data Warehouse.
This is a large EHR and claims data set.
Includes over 300 million individuals from health systems across the US with
various insurance types and longitudinal data on those individuals.
We took individuals who had a BMI measurement between 2016 and
2018,
were ages 40 plus, and had at least one prior year of observation in
the EHR data set, and we enrolled them in this
cohort. We divided our health systems, which were 54
total US health systems, into training health systems and validation health
systems.
So we had 4.9 million individuals in the training health
systems, which were 23 of the 54, and then 31 were the validation health
systems.
You can see the baseline characteristics, select baseline
characteristics of our validation cohort.
So the mean age was around 60, 79% of individuals were White,
57% female, 40% ever smoker with a mean BMI of 30
and a mean A1C of 6.4%.
Our incidence rate of PDAC in this population was higher than the US population
incidence rate due to the healthcare-seeking nature of the patients and the
exclusion of younger individuals younger than 40.
To develop our risk model in this population, we selected
a group of hypothesis-driven candidate variables, largely from this
phenome-wide association study conducted at NYU, in addition to a literature
review to identify other known or plausible risk factors for PDAC.
We then used an elastic net regression with cross-validation and
missing indicators for missing continuous variables to basically
parse down our candidate variables into independent and important
risk factors. We ultimately selected 19 final
variables, which were used to develop an unpenalized Cox
model in the training cohort with the selected variables, and our
outcome was incident PDAC as defined by ICD code.
So here are the 19 variables that were selected in our training
health systems, and you can see they include a number of sort of
common risk factors that we all know of for pancreatic cancer.
History of pancreatitis, history of other cancers,
demographics including older age, male sex,
Black race, metabolic and clinical variables including type 2
diabetes, abnormal weight loss, as well as various GI
conditions, and then laboratory values like A1C, glucose, lipase,
and AST, as well as type O blood and smoking
status.
This figure here displays the performance of our model in our 31
validation health systems. So you can see that the time-dependent area under
the curve at 24 months is 0.76 and then
0.75 at 36 months.
Additionally, the calibration of our model was good,
meaning the observed and predicted risk lined up well with a calibration slope of
1.02.
This displays hypothetical 36-month screening yield in the US validation
cohort. So if you were to take the top 1% of highest predicted risk individuals
per prime, these are individuals that have at least a 0.61%
absolute three-year risk of PDAC in our model.
Among these individuals, one of every 128 would actually develop PDAC within three
years, and this would comprise 5.8% of all PDAC cases that occurred
within three years. And you can see similar numbers as you drop the prime
percentile to the top 10%. You have a lower absolute risk threshold.
The NNS drops, but you do capture more cases.
Just to contextualize these data, you can see that conventional screening
mammography NNS is 125 to 500,
and then colonoscopy has an NNS for advanced adenomas or cancers of
53. So just to give you some context for guideline-recommended screening forms.
This plot shows risk stratification produced by our model in the validation cohort.
So this top red cumulative incidence curve is the top
percentile of predicted risk per prime.
The navy/black second to bottom
cumulative incidence curve is the 45th to 55th percentile prime
predicted risk, so median risk individuals.
And compared to the median risk individuals, the top predicted risk percentile
has a 7.6 times higher risk of developing PDAC
compared to these median risk individuals.This risk increase is
comparable to individuals with BRCA mutations and ATM
mutations, which are some of the more common PGVs associated with pancreatic
cancer. There are other pathogenic variants in different
genes that are less prevalent and have higher risk increases, but these are
indications currently for NCCN guideline recommended screening.
So we then deployed our model in the UK Biobank just to test,
first of all, how our model would perform in a very different clinical population.
The UK Biobank is largely white British.
It's known to be a healthy cohort. It's not necessarily a healthcare-seeking
population. It's a research population.
And it had a lower incidence of disease than our Optum clinical
cohort. And what you see is that there's a slight over-prediction of
risk with a calibration slope of 0.87 in this
cohort. And the AUC decreases slightly from
0.75 at 36 months to 0.71. But generally
speaking, the generalizability to this very different cohort is
relatively good.
We were also interested to see whether our high-risk individuals in our model were
actually individuals who do not have current guideline recommended
screening indications. And what we see is that the PRIME top one
percentile have PGVs in NCCN-defined
pancreatic cancer risk genes at a prevalence of
1.4%. This is relatively similar to the overall
prevalence of these mutations in the UK Biobank at
1.1%. So we're largely capturing individuals at sporadic
pancreatic cancer risk rather than genetic pancreatic cancer risk.
Our results were relatively consistent across sensitivity analyses,
including analyses meant to
sort of weed out individuals who may already be undergoing a workup for
PDAC, so individuals with PDAC within six months of index
date and individuals with recent abdominal imaging.
So again, I mentioned that we envision this model used in a sort of
sequential case-finding framework, so in which we first
define a high-risk population and then do blood-based biomarker
testing and then ultimately imaging.
So this is just a hypothetical sort of working through this
framework. So if we were to take a population of a million and
take the top 1% highest PRIME predicted risk individuals in this
population and test them with PancreasSure, which is a protein-based pancreatic
cancer assay with a published sensitivity of 80% and
specificity of 90%, we would expect to find 1,054
individuals who were positive, and those individuals would undergo
abdominal imaging. And assuming a sort of optimistic 100% sensitivity
of abdominal imaging for disease, we would identify 62
cases. So this is a positive predictive value of 5.9% with a
likelihood ratio of 47.
If we were to use a different type of blood-based biomarker, so a cell-free
DNA assay, which is known to have a lower sensitivity and a higher
specificity, we would of course have fewer individuals who are eligible
for imaging, 543,
and 47 PDACs identified, so fewer PDACs
identified. But we would have a higher positive predictive value,
demonstrating the trade-off between sensitivity and specificity in these classes of
biomarker assays.
So PRIME is important because it could expand early detection opportunities
for the 80% of patients who currently don't have guideline recommended
screening indications. It's interpretable.
It can be explained to a patient, and it can be implemented easily.
It uses routinely collected EHR data with procedures to handle missing
data, and it's validated across US health systems as well as the
UK Biobank. So in a future perspective validation and
case-finding study, we plan at NYU to flag
individuals with PRIME predicted absolute two-year risk of greater than
0.5%,
then test those individuals with blood-based biomarker tests, likely a
protein-based assay, and among individuals positive at
both first two steps of the sequence, we will then apply diagnostic imaging.
So I want to give acknowledgement to my co-authors, including my mentor, Dr.
Morgan Grams, at the NYU Division of Precision Medicine, my
colleagues at the Perlmutter Cancer Center, including Drs.
Ganda and Maitra, who were important in this study, as well as my colleagues
in population health. Feel free to contact me if you have any
questions. And I think we have a little bit of time for questions now as
well, and the full manuscript is available now in JAMA Oncology
via the QR code below if you want to know more details. Thank you.
I'll
ask a question about the methods. Great talk.
When you designed your models to do the prediction,
did you build in sort of balance between the two groups, the
PDAC group versus the not PDAC group?
Or you were able to predict even though it was a rare outcome?
Yeah. We didn't use any sort of class weighting.
We did not build in any balance.
Okay. And any thoughts about the prevalence of those
conditions and how those might fluctuate in different populations and
therefore impact the sensitivity and specificity?
So
the prevalence of the risk factors in the model?
Yeah, the risk factors.
Yeah. They certainly will vary across populations.
Like for example, in the UK Biobank, the prevalence of type 2 diabetes is much
lower than the Optum population. We
hope that if we're capturing real biological signal, that our absolute
risk predictions will be sort of calibrated across different prevalences of these
risk factors. But,
I think that's why
prospective validation of this sort of model will be important to
show that it's actually predicting risk correctly.
Thank you.
Yeah. Just great talk.
I was looking at your hypothetical model, which I really liked how you kind
of presented it, and you were thinking about-The second
step, looking at the imaging. Now, how are you thinking about using
that data? Because you've kind of alluded to the possibility
of detecting 62 cancers, but now with a lot
of improvements in using radiomics, AI
methods,
I was wondering,
why shouldn't we find even more potential cancers?
And so I didn't know what your approach was going from that step to the next.
So I guess if that was sort of unclear, so basically the 62 was
the number of cancers that were available to be detected.
So this is assuming we have a perfectly sensitive imaging test.
The rest of the drop off from 1,000 to
62 reflects the number of individuals who'd be imaged but not
have PDAC.
A question.
If
I were going to roll this and apply this to a health system,
can you comment on how you will manage contacting
potential people at risk and comment on the ethics of that too?
Yeah, I think that's one thing we've been sort of working on, including with our
IRB.
We don't want to alarm people with an unvalidated
model.
But I think
that potentially with the
collaboration with primary care doctor who's familiar with the patient in an ideal
setting, but I think that's something we need to work out still.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, everyone. I am Sheetal Hardikar.
I'm a faculty member at the University of Utah and an investigator at the
Huntsman Cancer Institute, and I am going to kickstart the
latter half of this session where we're looking at risk factors for
survival.
I have no financial relationships to disclose.
So, some of you may know that colorectal cancer is the second leading
cause of cancer-related mortality in the US, and
if you were at the Advances in Survivorship
session earlier today,
Dr. Kathy Eng actually mentioned that it is now the
leading cause of cancer-related mortality among younger men.
And just remember that, because it's going to come back in my presentation as well.
Patients with colorectal cancer are at a higher risk for
malnutrition and
also metabolic dysfunction. And this is particularly
common in older adults because older adults are inherently at a higher
risk for malnutrition.
Such a cancer-related malnutrition then can lead to increased
metabolism, and that results in an increased resting energy
expenditure,
and that may lead to conditions such as cachexia if it's combined
with muscle loss. And that's why
increased metabolism has been associated with several clinical
outcomes, including postoperative complications as well as
survival. Now there's various different ways to
measure metabolism in a patient. There's more
objective methods like calorimetry.
You probably have heard of the biophysical
impedance. One very simple way to
predict your metabolic rate is through these predictive
equations that have been developed over the years, and
we used one of the predictive equations to test
the association with survival. So
basal metabolic rate essentially represents your
essential daily expenditure,
which is required to maintain your bodily functions.
Again, it can be measured objectively, but it can be predicted through various
equations as well. In the current literature, high
basal metabolic rate has been associated with several
cancers, such as colorectal cancer, esophageal, and other
hormone-related cancers, and this has also been shown in large
epidemiologic cohorts, such as the EPIC cohort with half a million
individuals.
However, the association between basal metabolic rate
and cancer survival is as yet unclear.
We found only two studies, both done in
Asia and in gastric cancer patients, where these
predictive basal metabolic rate equations were used to
assess the relationship with survival.
And so we were just curious to understand whether this can be
used as a prognostic marker in colorectal cancer patients.
Oh,
sorry.
So our objective with this project was to investigate the
association of basal metabolic rate that we
captured at or around cancer
diagnosis with overall, as well as colorectal
cancer-specific survival, and we evaluated
differences by age of onset and sex.
So we did this in the prospective
international cohort called the COLO-CARE study.
This is a NCI-funded, multicenter
U01 cohort. It's currently in its second
funding cycle from the NCI, and we have six
centers in the United States and one center in Germany.
The centers are listed here. The coordinating center for the colorectal
study is at the Huntsman Cancer Institute.
And so thus far, we have recruited over 4,300
patients with colorectal cancer in this cohort, and we
have extensively phenotyped these patients.
So for this project, we used data on
3,760 patients from the COLO-CAIR study.
We used patients from all sides and all
stages of cancer.
Our primary exposure was basal metabolic rate using
these predictive equations. I'm not going to go over
how this predictive equation works and how the BMR was
calculated, but I put the image here so that you can see the
different loading factors. But briefly, it is an equation that comprises
of weight and height, and there's different loading
factors by sex and age. And that
represents how the metabolic needs of an
individual change over their life course, and of course,
differences by sex.
And then our outcomes were overall and cancer-specific
survival.
We used adjusted Cox proportional hazards
regression models adjusted for the factors that I've listed on the slide
there. And then we also conducted subgroup
analyses by age and
sex. So here's
briefly our study population characteristics.
We had approximately equal proportion of patients with colon and
rectal cancer. That's shown in the bottom left there.
And then we had a slightly higher proportion of males, shown on
the top left, and that corresponds with the
epidemiology of colorectal cancer.
Then we also observed that basal metabolic rate
declined with age, so the median
BMR was lower in the highest quartile.
And then BMR was higher in individuals with a high
BMI, and as has been shown in other
populations, we found a 28% higher mean
BMR in men. Men tend to have a higher basal metabolic rate than
women.
Here are our results for five-year survival
that I'm showing results for overall survival on the left and
colorectal cancer specific survival on the right.
You can see that patients in the highest BMR quartile
had approximately 23% reduced risk for overall survival
and about 36% reduced risk for colorectal
cancer-specific survival. And that has
been highlighted in those red boxes there.
And then if you
focus on the lower half of these panels where I'm
showing results by sex,
you can see that men, in general, experienced a better
overall survival compared to women at the same or a
higher BMR tertile.
And our results were slightly more pronounced for colorectal
cancer-specific survival.
Here I'm showing the results by
subgroup analyses by age and sex. And just to orient you, the
panel on the left shows the results for the overall cohort,
the middle panel is the results in females, and the panel on the
right shows the results in males.
Then if you focus on the leftmost panel for overall survival,
you can see that patients that were younger or under
65 years of age had generally a better survival than those
patients that were over 65 years of age.
And remember, these models were adjusted for
all the
relevant confounders.
And then
from my perspective, a really interesting result is that we
found that specifically in younger men under 50 years
of age, higher basal metabolic rate was
predictive of better survival,
almost a 70% better survival, and this was statistically
significant, as you can see from the panel on the
right. And then we did also see that women that were
older than 65 years generally had a better survival than
men that were over 65 years of age.
So
our study has several strengths and limitations.
This project was done in a very large cohort of
diverse
patients from all over the United States and international patients as well.
We had a multi-center design with a comprehensive long-term
follow-up.
The one big advantage from my perspective is that we
evaluated a very readily available exposure, the predicted
basal metabolic rate just needs weight, height, age, and
sex of the individual, and these are things that get measured pretty
much at every doctor's visit. And so can be easily
measured even in very limited
resource settings,
and can be easily translatable. However, this study was
not without limitations. Basal metabolic rate, again,
only uses
height, weight, age, and sex, and so it may not fully capture a patient's true
metabolic status. These equations, though they were
developed by the WHO
in a really large cohort of patients, they still don't
account for other factors such as race and ethnicity.
And we know that there's a lot of differences in metabolic needs and
diet, et cetera, based on race and
ethnicity. So these equations do not account for population diversity very
well. And then BMR could just be simply
a correlate that correlates with other conditions that
predict mortality but not really be
causal.Keep going back. I'm sorry.
And so,
to conclude, we did observe that basal metabolic rate
varied by age, sex, and obesity status.
We did show that patients with a high basal metabolic
rate in the highest quartile showed an improved
overall as well as colorectal cancer-specific survival, and
particularly among younger men.
And so,
this can be used, metabolic assessment around colorectal cancer diagnosis can
then be used to guide personalized interventions.
It could be predictive of when a patient is developing, let's say,
cachexia, or it can be used for designing
pre-habilitation related interventions and
also inform targeted survivorship strategies.
And then with that, I really want to acknowledge a lot of folks.
First of all, NCI for funding the ColoCare study.
All the large, fantastic team across the
world. I see a lot of people here in the audience, so thank you
for the support. But I definitely want to acknowledge
Ranran. She's sitting here in the audience.
She was a visiting scholar from Germany in my lab, and
she's done all of these analyses and our funding sources.
And then, as I wait to answer your questions, I want to leave you
all with some beautiful pictures of Utah.
We have a few open positions currently, so if any of you are
interested, please come talk to me,
and I'm happy to take any questions.
So, very nice talk.
So a few questions.
I must have missed some of the confounders that you adjusted for.
So things that are readily available, like Karnofsky score or
functional status, were those accounted for?
No, we didn't account for Karnofsky score here because we
haven't really abstracted Karnofsky score from all of our patients.
However, we did adjust for tumor site and
stage and other clinical factors like treatment
received. And so,
we were not able to adjust for frailty specifically, but
we did adjust, even within the age-stratified models, we further adjusted
for age to account for any residual confounding, and we
did still see these results. But that's a great question.
In a separate sub-cohort, we are evaluating frailty in
our cohort, and so hopefully in the future, we'll be able to account for
that.
And just as a follow-up, so I'm assuming the things like comorbidity burden are not
captured either?
No. We
have that data available. We didn't include that in the model.
We did include diet
as a confounder. Didn't see anything.
And then we didn't account for obesity,
smoking, and physical activity, though, in these models.
Okay. And then really quickly, so these folks all have imaging available to
them. So my question is,
how does this, in your mind, fit into the broader literature
around body composition-
Mm-hmm
... and muscle fat, et cetera, since this is a relatively crude measure?
Mm-hmm. Yeah, no, that's a great question.
These patients do get the clinical-- Clinically, they all get the
imaging done. We
currently are actually processing CT scans as part of another sister R01
on these patients, and so we haven't been able to correlate it with the body
composition measures, but once we have that data, we should be able to look at
that. But
my hope is that it does then correlate
with, so the patients that we're seeing that are suddenly having a high
BMR, if you measure it over time, then those will
correlate with cachexia or sarcopenia.
That's my hope.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Hi, Charles Lacson, Martha Cancer Center.
So do you guys have any comments about how
BMR is measured by bioimpedance, like body composition
scales, and how does that--
Like, what is the correlation between how that is measured and
how you're-
Mm-hmm
... calculating BMR?
Mm-hmm. So I am not
100% certain how the bioelectrical impedance
works, but there have been papers that have shown that
the BMR that's predicted with these equations, and these were
developed in the '80s prior to the BIA technology.
And so, they have looked at the correlation between the
predicted basal metabolic rate using these equations that again, we can
readily compute with just minimal data with the
bioelectrical impedance, and it correlates well.
But I
cannot speak to how the bioelectrical-
You don't know if there's any-
... impedance actually works
... misclassification based on how it's measured,
right?
Sorry, I couldn't--
You don't know if there's any misclassification based on how it's
measured.
The bioelectrical impedance?
Yeah.
How you calculate a BMR versus the bioelectrical impedance.
Yeah. I
don't remember off the top of my head what the sensitivity or the
positive predictive values were, but they do
correlate well. That's-
Thank you.
Yeah.
Thank you. Maryam Farid from George Mason University. I have some questions.
Maybe you mentioned, but I missed it.
Those measurements, before cancer diagnosis or after
cancer diagnosis?
So this is at our ColoCare study enrollment,
and so it's after cancer diagnosis for all of them.
For some, it's like the visit that they get diagnosed with cancer.
For some, it may be, depending just based on the referral patterns, it may
be shortly after diagnosis, but this is all after diagnosis.
During the time of treatment or, for example, the-
This is prior to treatment for most patients.
Patients.
And then,The question that I have, you
mentioned that we know that
this measure developed
for the healthy population.
Mm-hmm.
How do you know that it would be possible to use it for the
cancer survivor? Maybe they need adjustment in
some-
Mm-hmm
... factors for them. And as mentioned, that
might be different for the race, based on the race and
ethnicity and other things. And I'm thinking that might be different
for cancer survivor also.
The other question that I have, you mentioned that that might be different based on
the age. Yes, we know that. For example, in the formula, we have
age that is minus five-
Mm-hmm
... multiplied by age or other things.
So we expected that by increasing the age, that definitely
decrease the
BMR. That is something that based on the formula, we know about
it.
So when you look at this, and then as long as we have the
age in the formula, how do you
check BMR based on the age of the population?
You know that you did it based on young and then the older
population. And then mentioned that the higher
BMR in younger survivors
associated with lower risk of mortality, and then it's in
the higher
at the participants at age 65 or older
associated with a higher risk of mortality.
As long as you have the age in the formula-
Mm-hmm
... thinking that how do you stratify the population
based on the age, as long as we have this age confounded
recalculating the formula that you have.
Mm-hmm.
It is a confounded that you have age in the
formula that calculating the BMR, and then you
stratify-
There are also-
... the population based on the age also.
Mm-hmm. These are great questions.
So to answer your first question, there are no predicted
equations for any special population, such as cancer
patients.
That is definitely-- And you're right.
It may be the loading factors may be slightly different in
disease populations because the
WHO-adopted equations are obviously in healthy individuals.
But that's what we have, and that's been used, again, in
many published
papers for cancer risk.
So
to answer that question, there are no
equations specifically in disease population, so we just used what we have.
To answer your second question, yes, age is included in
the
BMR calculation. However, it's, again, broad age groups, and so
we adjusted for age further so that to account within that age group,
even if there's differences
by increasing age within a group, then that
gets adjusted by adjusting for that factor in our
models. I don't know if that answers your question.
Yeah. That's good. Thank you.
Thank you.
Hello, everyone. My name is Sakshat Chintala from UC
San Diego.
I'm here to present our patient-level and claim-level
analysis of telehealth disparities in older cancer
patients.
This work is part of the CREATE partnership between
UC San Diego and San Diego State University.
I have no conflicts of interest to disclose.
To set the stage, before COVID-19, the
utilization of telehealth was negligible,
under 1%.
The March 2020 waivers removed geographic barriers and
expanded coverage,
and the utilization surged up to 29%
in 2020 and settling at 15% since.
However,
telehealth adoption varies by specialty.
Cancer care is uniquely complex.
Encounters like surgery, chemotherapy, and
radiation occur in person, while encounters like
counseling, symptom handling,
are amenable to telehealth. Our study specifically
focuses on looking at oncology telehealth
utilization among the older cancer patients.
Our preliminary data from UCSD Moores Cancer Center
sets our motivation for this project.
Among over 29,000 cancer encounters,
Hispanic patients, Asian patients,
low-income patients, and Spanish speakers all significantly had
lower telehealth utilization, and these barriers
persisted over time.
There's a broader
gap in literature as well.
Single institution studies might show conflicting results due to their
small sample sizes.
And no national level analysis looking at oncology
telehealth utilization exists yet.
And prior work only looked at one level of
utilization. Both ASCO and MedPAC have
exactly called out for this kind of research.
Our objective was to categorize disparities in
oncology telehealth utilization at two
complementary levels.
First, at the patient level, we asked the question:
Who utilized telehealth?... basically
within their first year of diagnosis.
At claim level, we looked at the engagement patterns among the
users who did utilize telehealth, and also looked at how
provider and system-level factors are associated with the
telehealth delivery.
So we used Medicare fee-for-service
claims from 2019 through 2021, over
1.1 million cancer patients across
six cancer types, generating nearly 70 million
oncology claims.
We identified oncology telehealth utilization using
the E&M CPD codes, along with the modifier
associated with the cancer provider.
We did the analysis using
multi-variable logistic regression
model, and also did the per-user engagement analysis.
So overall, 14.1% of the cancer
patients utilized telehealth at least once within
their first year of diagnosis.
Utilization rates went from 7.7% in
2019, to 21.2% in 2020,
to 16.2% in 2021. By
race, rates ranged from
11.2% in the Black population, all the way to
17.9% in Asian and Pacific
Islander. There's also
a clear gap that we can notice
among the age groups as well.
There's basically a steep gradient as you get older.
And there's also a gap that we can notice between the urban
and the rural population when it comes to utilization too.
This is a figure looking at the patient-level factors
associated with the oncology telehealth use.
Again, we can clearly notice there's a steep age
gradient when we look at the age here.
Another factor that we can notice is among
the race and ethnicity variable. Black population
utilized telehealth much lower
than compared to the non-Hispanic White population.
And Asian and Pacific Islander population had the
highest utilization in comparison to the non-Hispanic White
population as well. We can also notice there's a substantial gap
again, when we look at the rural and
urban geography
of the patients too. And given the expansion of
telehealth after COVID-19,
patients have also utilized telehealth a lot more in
2020 than compared to 2019. And then it started
to stabilize a little lower after
the 2020 year.
So until now, we've looked at
which patients have utilized
telehealth and how the rates look like.
But this slide kind of talks about how the
engagement
sustains. So among the users who did
use telehealth,
we can clearly notice that Asian and Pacific Islander
patients are least likely to be one and done.
They're also highly likely to have four or
more visits
in comparison to non-Hispanic White population.
Hispanic population also follows a similar story
here. But when we look at the Black population,
among the patients at least who did use telehealth,
most of them have only one visit, and it
drops down,
or they
basically
don't tend to use telehealth utilization
furthermore.
There was also much lower uptake and mild engagement
gap when we looked at the age category and the
geography variable too, imposing that primarily
it could be access-driven.
We also looked at provider and system-level factors
that might influence telehealth delivery.
APPs, female providers, and academic
facilities have shown to
deliver higher
telehealth delivery in comparison to the
physician oncologists versus male providers and non-academic
facilities respectively. So this
frames the problem in a different way as well, that
the disparities don't exist within the patient side too,
but the provider and system-level factors also play
a vital role in equitable access.
In conclusions, are four things to talk
about. So our dual approach analysis kind of
reveals disparities that single-level studies might miss.
Different subgroups face different barrier profiles.
Provider characteristics may be highly effective for
improving equitable access.
Sustainable telehealth reimbursement is essential for continued
equity gains. Our ongoing work also
includes looking at association of telehealth
impact on quality of care and safety
outcomes. We're also working on designing
and releasing patient-level and provider-level surveys too to kind of
understand the why question, which
our claims data couldn't answer because it kind of answers
the what. So we also wanted to release the surveys and
understand the barriers among both patients
and providers.To close, I would like
to thank my PIs,
Dr.
Javier Deloz and Dr. Parada, who are the PIs of the project,
and also my mentors,
Dr. Banegas and Dr. Rose, and my team at
UCSD CHEO and also at SDSU.
Thank you so much, and I'm happy to take any questions.
That was a great talk. I'll just ask about the barriers
after initiation for telehealth, whether you've begun
to identify what some of those might be for those populations in
terms of translating these findings in the future.
Yes. We have conducted a survey looking at the prostate
cancer cohort itself from 2019 until 2024
at UCSD Moores Cancer Center. Most of the cases can
include, one, digital literacy, or two, the
broadband access.
I think provider relationship also plays
an important role. When a patient comes in for the
first time and sees a provider, but the second time they
come in, if it's a different provider, it's hard to maintain that
sustainable relationship so that they can keep coming
back and utilize telehealth. Also, if they did face
some barriers during their first visit,
they tend to pivot from utilization again.
But
most of the patients at
UCSD Moores Cancer Center did find
telehealth as a proper addition
to cancer care, obviously because most of the cancer care
occurs in person. But it's definitely, I think, a very good
addition to have to help the patient, especially when they live
very far. And if it's something like
encounters,
like counseling,
can be done through telephone or video conference.
Excellent. Thank you very much.
Thank
you.
Okay, so good afternoon, everyone.
My name is Houyi Zhang, and I'm an earth stem and tenure-track investigator
at National Cancer Institute. So it's my great pleasure
to present the CONFLUENCE Project, which is an unprecedented
effort
for breast cancer genome-wide association study.
We have been able to pull more than two million participants from diverse
ancestries. And at this scale, we are able to uncover some of the genetic
insights which are not even possible before.
I have no financial relationship to disclosure.
So genome-wide association study for breast cancer has been successful
so far. Up to today, there are around 240 risk
loci being identified and explaining around 30%
of the familial risk for breast cancer.
However, the GWAS data for breast cancer are
mainly from European ancestry, and the corresponding polygenic risk score developed
based on this data showed reduced performance in non-European
ancestry. Now, this disparity actually matters a lot because breast
cancer is the most common cancer in women worldwide.
Roughly per year, there are more than two million women diagnosed,
and the lifetime risk for women is roughly one in eight.
So to address this gap,
we have built this CONFLUENCE project, which is the largest
and most ancestrally diverse project for breast cancer GWAS.
CONFLUENCE is actually a consortium of consortium, where there are six major
participating consortium of CONFLUENCE from different ancestries, and there are
also multiple biobanks, which are contributing data to CONFLUENCE.
Up to today, there are around 290 studies from 61 different
countries in CONFLUENCE. And the goal of CONFLUENCE is simple and
also very ambitious, including identifying novel risk loci
associated with breast cancer risk,
develop a polygenic risk score that is truly generalizable across different
ancestries, identify potential loci which are associated with
prognosis and long-term survival.
Last and the most important is trying to build a reusable data sources
that is open to the whole scientific community.
So CONFLUENCE is the largest breast cancer GWAS that has been ever
conducted. Compared to the most recent multi-ancestry GWAS
effort for breast cancer, based on the effective sample size,
CONFLUENCE contributed more than three times larger sample size, and we have been
able to analyze data that has roughly
227,000 cases and around
1.7 million controls.
And CONFLUENCE is not only about increasing the sample size, we have also
put a decent effort of trying to increase the sample size for all non-European
ancestries. In this figure, it shows the effective sample size for
five major ancestries in CONFLUENCE.
From the left to right, it includes African and mixed
American, East Asian, Middle Eastern, and South Asian.
And we have been able to double the effective sample size for every single
non-European ancestry in CONFLUENCE.
So as you can imagine, there are so many different studies and arrays
contributing to CONFLUENCE. So the quality control
process takes a humongous effort.
And we have paid a lot of efforts trying to harmonize the genotype quality
process to ensure all the data are processed in a consistent way.
And all the data are imputed to top matching panel, and in total, there are
around 45 million variants analyzed within CONFLUENCE.
Association study have been done based on Regeni, adjusting for top 10
principal components. And additionally, GWAS summary statistics
from 20 different external biobanks has been included in this
effort.So, this is a
Manhattan plot of the Confluence meta-analysis.
This is combining all ancestries together, overall breast cancer studies, and
we have been able to identify 545 independent loci.
And this number defined is based on three very stringent criteria,
including all the index variant for each loci need to be 500
KB away from each other, and their LD need to be less than
0.1, and D-prime need to be less than 0.3.
And you need to fulfill all the three criteria simultaneously to be defined as
one independent loci.
And we also ensure every single contributing study
have very well type 1 error control.
As you can see, the total genomic inflation factor is only
1.11 for this kind of large-scale study, indicating a very
well-controlled type 1 error. The minimum allele frequency we have been able to
go to is 0.03%, and the number of genomewide significant variants
is more than 63,000.
And after removing all the previously published loci by
any literature, following very similar stringent criteria to define
at least one novel loci, we have been able to identify more than
273 novel loci which haven't been published by any previous
literature.
And based on the GWAS, we have also conducted a preliminary
PRS analysis. This PRS is the simplest PRS.
It is constructed directly based on the genomewide significant variants.
The index loci will take out two major biobanks from the analysis,
UK Biobank and All of Us. And the PRS building process is
completely independent from these two biobank to ensure the independence of PRS
construction.
The variant entering this PRS is 544 because one of the loci is
only UK Biobank available. We compared against a widely
used 313-variant breast cancer PRS, which has been actually implemented
in some of the clinical trials to test PRS efficiency in
breast cancer prevention. And we also acknowledge there are
many advanced PRS approaches that can actually accounting for LD
effect size and the minor allele frequency differences across ancestries.
And there has been effort in multiple different ancestries to
apply these approaches and show better performance.
But for today, we will only compare with the 313 PRS because there are
ongoing efforts for applying the others.
So here, this is the results comparing the Confluence
544 variant PRS with the 313 variant PRS within
UK Biobank, European ancestry. We see a significant improvement
for 2% of AUC. So our engineered 313 PRS is roughly
63%, and the Confluence PRS is around 65% with significant
performance.
And we take this PRS also evaluated in the other very
ancestry diverse, All of Us cohort with three major ancestry,
European, African, and mixed American.
And we see consistent improvement with 2% to 3% AUC
improvement and all significant across all three major
ancestries, which is indicating this PRS show very robust
portability across multiple biobanks, which are totally independent from the
developing process.
So ongoing efforts and planned analysis in Confluence including trying
to identify additional loci based on ancestry-specific GWAS and
across different subtypes, and also applying more advanced PRS
approaches to accounting for the effect size, allele frequency, and the LD
differences across the different ancestries.
And there are also several other major ongoing effort, including fine mapping to
identify underlying causal variants, rare variant association testing,
identify variants that is associated with prognosis and long-term survival, and
also evaluated the effect size differences across male and female for breast
cancer.
I also want to mention, we put a very decent effort to ensure this resource is
actually reusable to the whole community.
So once the main paper get published, GWAS summary statistics will be released
immediately to the community. And this platform, Confluence data platform,
people can submit proposals directly and
request individual data access. The data will be hosted on a cloud platform where
it's following a similar model as UK Biobank and All of Us, and then you can submit
a proposal and get a data access.
So in conclusion, Confluence is largest multi-ancestry breast cancer GWAS to
date, including around 427,000 cases,
1.7 million controls. We have identified
545 independent risk loci, substantially
increasing the genetic risk across ancestry groups.
And also
the PRS, a preliminary PRS built based on Confluence genomewide
significant variants, outperforms the widely used 313 PRS
in two biobanks across multiple ancestries.
So
Confluence is a very collaborative, international collaborative effort,
and there are multiple analyses from every single consortium contributing to this
effort. And I want to sincerely acknowledge every one of them because without their
effort, this presentation is not even possible.
I also want to sincerely thank all the Confluence contributing collaborators,
including the six major consortium that is contributing individual data
and the 20 external biobanks that is contributing summary statistics and the
NCI's Cancer Genomic Research Lab, which put a decent
effort of genotyping, quality control imputation, and also
the NCI Intramural funding, which without the funding is not even possible.
So last at the end, I also want to mention NCI is a great place for
research, and we offer fellowships for pre-doc, post-doc,
post-bachelor, and if you are interested, feel free to scan the QR code
and thank you so much. I'm happy to take any questions.
Yeah. Thank you very much. This is really
very nice. Confluence is really needed because
I'm a medical oncologist from Yale University, from University of
Chicago. And the question that comes up in the
clinic when you offer genetic testing
is how do you implement
... better risk assessment tools in the clinic.
And so I think the geographic heterogeneity and the fact
that you are able to replicate is a major
strength of Confluence. But my question is, do we
need a larger sample size, or do you
need to dig deeper into African genomes that are
diverse and they also form the genetic
basis of all the human race?
Yeah. So that's a very nice question.
So,
as we showed here,
of course, Confluence put a decent effort trying to increase the non-European
sample size. But if you actually look at the European sample size, it's still
much larger than any of the non-European.
So with the external biobanks contributing, it's also contributing a lot on the
European ancestry. So I think there are definitely some space trying
to increase the non-European sample size and also for better reference panel
to better impute them and to get a better recovery of some of
the lower frequency loci. So I think the answer is yes, of course, there
are much more effort to be gone trying to recover the
genetic heritability based on the genetic data.
Okay. All right. Thank you so much.
Yeah.
Okay. All right.
Yeah. So, we have about 10 minutes, and I just wanted to
commend the speakers because we've had a fabulous array of talks,
from prevention to survivorship across the spectrum, thinking about risk
prediction and precision oncology.
So I'd like to invite the speakers to come back up, and we're going to just have
a few minutes of conversation about the
translation of some of these findings
among the panelists. So we'll just...
Thanks, everybody for...
And these panelists were all asked to submit questions that
they would be interested in discussing.
And what was very interesting is that almost everyone submitted a
question about what's next for translation and what are some of the
barriers to translation. And Fumi actually kicked this off for us
by asking what's next. So,
to any of you,
we also have another microphone that I can bring up.
But please, what are your thoughts on barriers
to the translation of your precision findings?
Thank you. I think in my
particular case, for an EHR-based risk model,
prospective
validation is going to be critical to translation because there's
limitations in the EHR data. And so many of the risk models that have been
developed before, I think, have
sort of captured, to some degree, coding patterns and sort of
EHR artifacts. And our model likely isn't immune to that as well.
So I think
figuring out how the model works prospectively and
figuring out how many people who are deemed high risk want to
participate in our study and want to get further
screening, and figuring out the absolute risk threshold that is appropriate to
screen people at, all require sort of prospective assessment, even though the
EHR data is great for developing this kind of model.
All right. So I guess for the PRS case, it's
lucky to work on the German mutation because the effect size, if you look at the
PRS effect across different age range, it's generally very robust.
So it's independent of many other risk factors and
it's a good risk prevention tool because it's kind of robust
and the signal is very portable. Of course, the effect size varies a lot.
But regarding the barrier, even with the most simple
PRS, with the same effect size, same PRS, everything, and you apply
on different ancestries, you see the distribution varies a lot by different
ancestries without even considering their effect size differences.
And then when you look at it in clinics, it's like, what is a good cutoff?
Like when I define, here, I take top 10% of quantile
for some ancestry, it may be another quantile for the other ancestry.
So I guess for me, it's like, what's the best way to calibrate these
differences across major ancestries?
And what do we mean by
high-risk group based on PRS? Because
whether it's odds ratio more than two or absolute risk more than three, and they
are based on prevalence difference across major ancestries.
So I think for me, the collaboration across ancestries
and also trying to integrate this information with multiple other risk
factors where although PRS is robust, but other things may be
missing here or there are major co-variants missing here and there.
And then how to really integrate them together to deliver a pass-and-warnings model
that can be used in the clinics.
Does this work? Okay.
So I think for gastric cancer, the main challenge right now is that
there is no
base population screening for gastric cancer here in the United States,
but it should be a must for some minority groups,
as I already discussed, these minority
racial ethnic groups. So in last year, there was
a guideline
about the gastric cancer screening, that they said that
it's not possible to recommend even a
screening for these specific groups because there's not
enough evidence how this screen
will help to
capture gastric cancer earlier in these
populations. So the challenge here is for gastric
cancer, as it's a lethal disease,
and for these minority groups, the mortality is
very high. How we can put this
policy for at least
screen these
high-risk groups. So that will be the challenge.
Okay, thank you. Maybe I'll switch to another question.
And
the right-hand side of the panel, I think,
in common among you was some discussion of modification,
some of the factors that are modifiable that vary
across the population. I wonder if when you think about precision
oncology models, do you have thoughts on how we need to be
contending with variability and heterogeneity in the population so that
we don't worsen disparities as we roll out these kinds
of models?
Okay.
As a technology such as AI,
I think it can help me to
integrate those risk factors to
integrate
progression prediction
model to improve the
performance.
And
I think
it may be a validation in
different people.
Mm.
So I think it makes sense.
Handling it during training and validation. Yeah. Okay.
Yes.
Very good.
My work was not prediction modeling, but I-
Correct. Yes
... completely appreciate your question, and I got some questions to that.
And to definitely understanding our exposures in the
context of various different populations and
how your exposures change with different
populations.
The basal metabolic rate was developed in just
a large population but does not account for some important factors
like race, ethnicity. So the next step is to understand how
it varies between these different subgroups.
Of course, we didn't have as much
sample size to evaluate in the smaller subgroups, but there's more work to be done
in that.
Thank you.
So to your questions about
precision oncology and how the effect could
be different across different subgroups, it is highly
related to my talk earlier about breast
cancer, because different subtypes of breast cancer may
have very different risk factor profiles.
And
in some way, we can consider them as distinct diseases.
And so I think understanding
how nutrition impact each of these
subtype is important for recommendation and
cancer prevention, and
just being able to tell different groups of patients what is
the best nutrition for them.
Great, thank you.
Thank you for your question. I believe when it comes to looking
at the data itself,
each level of analysis gives us a different perspective,
especially in the study that we did.
Looking at patient level revealed the disparities just within
the patient side. But it was also important to look at
the claim level or visit level, too, so that we can also
consider how the system level and provider level factors
influence. So I believe, at least when it
comes to working with the data itself,
there's always a different story we can
look at depending on this perspective that we go with.
So yeah.
Great, thank you. Well,
I'd like to just invite everybody to give another round of
applause to this amazing group of speakers.
And thank you all for your time today.